Hope to set up tracking and
goals with Google analytic.
The first step would be to gain a code
from Google Analytic that will let it
execute on your website.
The best way to do it is to go
to Google Analytic Website, and
click on the Admin section then you
could click here and add a new account.
You could choose here between
a Website to your Mobile app.
Give it a meaningful name like demo1.
In my case it will be Ido's project.
And let's give it a URL.
And from here of course,
you need to decide in which
category you are going to be.
In our case it's Internet,
the Time Zone, and
some other aspects of the data
sharing that you're going to do.
And by clicking getting tracking ID
you're basically accepting of course,
the terms of use of Google Analytic.
And after you accept them
you'll get the tracking code.
Here it is.
With the right information,
how to put it on your website.
Once we do this preliminary phase,
we can jump into setting up our goals.
The first way to set goals is
because goals are very versatile way
to measure how well our site or
app fulfills target objectives.
You can set up individual goals for
discreet actions like, how many
users reach out our thank you page?
What are the top exlending pages?
What are the bounce rates on each one?
Where do people interact with the site?
Let's take for example,
my own site and set up a goal.
I'm clicking on the Admin to
get into the Admin tab and
then I'm clicking on Goals.